le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
préparez son avenir apprendre un métier
quand on était étudiant on apprend à
gérer son temps ses obligations mais
aussi son argent
les études sont gratuites dans la
plupart des établissements publics mais
pour faire ses études il faut parfois
aller assez loin se loger faire des
stages acheter des livres et des
fournitures scolaires tout cela a un
coût et malheureusement tous les foyers
n'ont pas forcément la possibilité et
les moyens financiers d'assumer les
dépenses alors Thomas fumait
financièrement ses études qui peut
apporter son soutien on en parle
maintenant dans lien social
Jérémy est un jeune garçon motivé et
ambitieux conscient des difficultés pour
trouver un travail il a décidé
d'augmenter ses chances en obtenant des
diplômes de valeur
titulaire d'un BTS il va continuer ses
études en licence mais comme tous les
étudiants Jérémy doit faire des achats
pour manger se déplacer vivre tout
simplement
en tant qu'étudiant il n'a pas de
revenus fixes les bourses proposées par
l'État ne suffisent pas à assumer ses
dépenses alors jérémy a fait une demande
à netbourse un service et une aide mis
en place par le Conseil Général pour
soutenir les jeunes Réunionnais pendant
leurs études
le service
est très utile parce que étant étudiant
en poste bas c'est la même vraiment
d'autres mes déplacements au quotidien
c'est à dire au niveau des frais de
déplacements les licence pour ma voiture
ça m'est très utile dans tout ce qui est
fournitures pour les livres qui sont
beaucoup plus chers aussi sa maîtrise au
niveau en général car cette bourse
complète la brosse que j'ai du
CROUS le service est très très facile
parce que tout le monde a accès Internet
et c'est très rapide de remplir le
formulaire pour pouvoir avoir accès à
cette bourse
comme Jérémy Cloé a fait en sorte
d'aller le plus loin possible dans ses
études sérieuse studieuse et responsable
elle se donne les moyens d'obtenir un
bon travail pour s'offrir un avenir
stable et une carrière professionnelle
mais avant d'avoir son premier salaire
elle est bien obligée de gérer son petit
budget pour obtenir ces diplômes Chloé
doit faire un stage à l'étranger sans
argent elle ne pourrait pas y arriver
mais avec l'aide de netbourse elle a pu
faire son stage et donc continuer ses
études comme je suis actuellement en BTS
Commerce International je dois effectuer
un stage de deux mois et demi à
l'étranger donc moi j'ai été en Chine et
aussi une mission export pour le compte
d'une entreprise réunionnaise netbourse
est vraiment adapté aux nouvelles
technologies car il est vraiment très
facile de s'inscrire avec soit un
smartphone même avec une tablette je
conseille à tous les jeunes comme moi
de s'inscrire sur netbourse car c'est
vraiment très efficace très rapide vous
avez tout à gagner rien à perdre et
franchement c'est vraiment un bon
complément financier en ce qui concerne
les études
grâce à netbourse beaucoup d'étudiants
comme Jérémy et Chloé augmentent leur
chance de réussir dans leurs études et
donc leur vie professionnelle sur
l'initiative de Nassima dinar la
présidente le Conseil général via en
outre de simplifier les formalités et
les critères d'attribution permettant
ainsi à plus de jeunes et leurs parents
de bénéficier des aides départementales
tout devient cher pour les parents comme
pour les étudiants et au conseil général
nous n'avons pas voulu sacrifier notre
jeunesse et l'ambition que nous avions
pour elle en les amenant en plus haut
niveau la bourse départementale est
élargie cette année à toute la classe
moyenne avec une bourse qui peut aller
jusqu'à 2150 euros de bourse plus les
frais de scolarité plus élevés jusqu'à
6000 euros pour aider la jeunesse
réunionnaise cette année le dispositif
est simplifié seul le revenu et le
critère
de prise en compte pour l'examen de la
demande de bourse ce qui va permettre à
plus d'étudiants de rentrer dans le
dispositif et donc toute la classe
moyenne peut aussi en être bénéficiaire
cette année une aide un dispositif un
soutien une solution netbourse c'est
tout ça en même temps un service
efficace qui utilise les outils modernes
rapides un moyen d'apporter de l'aide à
la jeunesse réunionnaise qui fera la
réunion de demain
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais